Marvel's ABC TV series Inhumans made its
long-awaited debut with a modified
version of the first two episodes
landing in IMAX theaters across the
country unfortunately the reaction from
critics and fans has not been kind the
theatrical release currently is yet to
earn a single positive review on Rotten
Tomatoes the box-office take has been
anemic and fans have been left wondering
how a project that spent such a long
time in development is turning out to be
Marvel's first massive flop there are
several factors that brought Inhumans to
this point so let's take a look at where
this project went so wrong red light
green light
Inhumans was first announced in 2014 as
part of Marvel Studios slate of then
upcoming theatrical releases and it was
intended at the time to be included in
Phase three
the inhuman royal family was never the
most high-profile of Marvel's stable of
characters but at the time of the
announcement the studio was coming out
the surprise smash hit guardians of the
galaxy featuring an ensemble of
characters whose profiles had previously
been even lower there seemed to be no
reason for concern until April 2016 when
the project was pulled from Marvel's
schedule at first Marvel studio head
honcho Kevin Feige said the release date
was just being shuffled to make room for
a solo spider-man movie and a sequel to
ant-man
but then the project moved to the small
screen with ABC and things got even
weirder we've been hiding here too long
let's go to our rightful home rumors
persisted that the project was in danger
of being scrapped altogether and many
fans were surprised when casting
announcements soon began to hit the web
and then disappointed once teaser images
soon followed terrible teasers the
inhuman royal family consists of some of
the most colorful and outlandish
characters in Marvel Comics you've got
Medusa's swirling deadly red locks and
Gorgon sci-fi fantasy aesthetic and the
fish man Triton so the series visual
design calls for some serious artistic
flair but when the first teaser images
of the cast and costume were released it
quickly became apparent that we were not
going to get that fans immediately
voiced their dismay on social media
Medusa in particular was singled out as
her hair was less of a special effect
and more of a really bad wig the
bargain-basement feel of the crucial
first
emotional image didn't do anything to
increase their anticipation of what
should have been a visual spectacle and
the trailers weren't much better despite
an appearance by the teleporting dog
locked jaw getting a positive response
pretty much every other aspect of the
trailer was widely criticized Medusa
again underwhelmed as fans got not even
a tease of what her hair could do and
some even began to wonder if her
abilities would make it into the show at
all the second trailer resolved that
issue but only by employing some of the
worst CGI effects this side of a
ten-year-old sci-fi movie a preview
shown at San Diego comic-con also left
fans to riding the new footage as
aggressively awful so instead of hype
the imagery only earned gripes awkward
press panel a few weeks prior to the
release of the IMAX presentation abc-tv
held its annual press event with the
Television Critics Association when the
cast of Inhumans came out to talk to the
assembled journalists it became quickly
apparent that they may not have been
ready to field question after question
about the poor internet reaction of the
trailers and the show's perceived lack
of quality Anson mount for example
responded to questions about the poor
reception by saying they made him feel
like Ben Affleck during the Batman vs
Superman tour we have spoken and I agree
and the rest of the cast members were
viewed as evasive deflective and
somewhat bewildered by what they were up
against Marvel TV Chief Jeff lobe even
snapped at reporters and shut the event
down early of course the cast may have
had a reason to be on edge imperiled
production the plan to divert tin humans
from the silver to the small screen
meant that producers had just months to
cast write and develop an eighth episode
miniseries from an already ambitious
basis making matters worse the IMAX
premiere the first two episodes meant
that those episodes would have to be
produced on an extremely accelerated
schedule those episodes director role
renee revealed that although the process
was collaborative
he was definitely under the studio's
thumb all the while telling CNET there
was always a Marvel executive around me
just to make sure that whatever I did or
whatever we did together would tie in
with other characters in other universes
in
they're comics in other series or movies
they were very protective
the rushed nature of the production is
apparent in the finished product and the
fact that some scenes are gorgeously
shot in IMAX actually hurts
rather than helps the IMAX experiment
critics have pointed out that the scenes
that are shot in IMAX look fantastic
but that they also make it even more
apparent which scenes were not the
interiors and costumes have every bit
the low-budget aesthetic suggested by
the trailers flaws that are only
magnified up on that gigantic screen
with the gorgeous IMAX footage
occasionally popping in to make the rest
of the film look even worse by
comparison
we're in humans and the first week of a
planned two-week run in humans grossed
about 1.5 million which is a paltry sum
compared to the promotional expenses
while an investment by IMAX will make
Inhumans profitable for Disney no matter
what happens it's not exactly
encouraging for partnerships of this
kind in the future critical miss in the
summer of flailing film studios blaming
critics for killing their box office
returns Inhumans is no exception
reviewers overwhelmingly railed on what
they saw in the series from the acting
to direction to set design and even
special effects some have gone so far as
to call it the worst thing Marvel has
done and after the critical lashing that
Marvel TV execs took for iron fists that
says a lot
perhaps the fact that the studio gave
the reins of the show to Iron Fist
showrunner Scott Buck can be blamed for
that double dose of disses after all
iron fist failed to live up to
expectations for similar reasons both
shows were rushed in conception and
execution poorly written and plotted and
indifferent ly staged and photographed
whether or not the failure of Inhumans
is part of any trend of declining
quality among Marvel TV productions is
up for debate but if buck is allowed to
go to bat for a third Marvel property
he's gonna have two strikes against him
already thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]